اتهم محمد حمدان دقلو قائد قوات الدعم
السريع في السودان قياده الجيش في العمل
وفق توجيهات فلول النظام السابق كان ذلك
خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات
اولها على اي نحو يمكن ان تنعكس تصريحات
قائد الدعم السريع بشان المفاوضات ما هي
العقبات التي قادت الى توقف مفاوضات جده
ما الذي يضيفه حديث واشنطن عن محاوله
فاجنر لادخال مضادات جويه الى السودان
حماتي عندما ظهر اليوم يعني سجل نقاط
كثيره منها يعني ردا على شائعات الكثيره
ومره اخرى انه بين قواته وانه قادر على
اتخاذ القرارات وانه بامكانه هزيمه هذا
التوجه اقصد توجه الحرب واعتقد ان ليس
هنالك اي رساله جديده دائما في ربك في
الخطاب يعني
بتقدموا بيقدمون المبردين هي تريد اتفاق
مثلا في جده وقعت عليه ان تخرج من بيوت
المواطنين ان تخرج من المغاره الحكوميه
وان تقل المستشفيات تاكيد لتصريحات سابقه
وهي اتهامات الى قياده الجيش بانها مسيطر
عليها وانها غير قادره على اتخاذ قرار
بصوره مستقله للمضي قدما في مساله السلام
ظلت تكذب في بياناته
مزيد من الضغط على القياده الحاليه هي
انها اما اذا تذهب الى التفاوض او انها
يعني ربما تستسلم او ربما تجبر على
الاستسلام القيادات القيادات في فئه
اماكنها ومنذ اليوم الاول تعمل على تصفيه
هذا التمرد
بعض النقاط تم تجاوزها منذ الجوله الاولى
للمفاوضات هو انه لن ينسحب احد من الاماكن
التي يعني موجود بها الان اذا كان هناك
قاعده عسكريه في جبره فانك لا تستطيع ان
تسحب الدعم السريع من جبر ما لم توقع
اتفاق كيف يمكن ان يتحدث عن ايقاف الحرب
او مفاوضات وهو يحتل نيوتن المواطنين حتى
المساعدات الانسانيه التي جاهد عبر
بورسودان وصلت الى الجزيره تم نهبها
وبالتالي لم يستفيد المواطن لحل الازمه
اصبحت واضحه فوق عليها المتمردون في جده
حين انتقلنا الى مرحله التنفيذ لم تنفذ
الميليشيا ما تم الاتفاق عليه والان
يريدون ان تتوقف الحرب القضايا الجوهريه
هي قضايا الخلافه السياسي حول الفتره
الانتقاليه مثلا انتقال السلطه اصلاح
الامن والعسكري لن يستطيع الجيش ان يفعل
ذلك ولن يقبل الشعب السوداني بان يوقع
اتفاق سياسي او عسكري بدون خروج ماليزيا
المحتله لمنازله واللي بتغتصب بنزائه
وبتخسر في في المواطنين الذي يطيل الامد
الحرب هو الذي يستنفر المواطنين للدخول في
الحرب هو الذي يرفض التفاوض هو الذي ايضا
لا يريد القبول بحقائق موضوعيه بالشماعه
شايفين هو المجتمع الدولي يعني
يعزف فيها انه والله على هوى المجتمع
الدولي انهم عايزين ديمقراطيه الفلوس مع
جيل الاسلام السياسي دي اجنده اصلا ما في
خيال هذه المليجيا ولا عندها طاقه فكريه
ولا ثقافيه ولا عندها تنظير حوله جديده هي
مطالبه الاطراف وكذلك المجتمعات المستفيده
من التغيير الحقيقي والكبير في هيكل
السلطه وكذلك في وفي برامج السلطان
هذا الخبر يعني لا يمكن التاكد من صحته
الان الان نحن في الشهر الرابع لم يحتج
الدعم السريع الى مثل هذه الاسلحه حتى
يحقق محققه خلال فتره الماضيه الموضوع اخر
له علاقه بمصالح اقتصاديه متعلقه بتنقيب
عن الذهب في الحدود الحدود افريقيا الوسطى
ما تبقى من المعارك لا يتطلب اسلحه كبيره
او اسلحه نوعيه او يعني مضادات للطائرات
وهو كان منتشرا وموجودا في كل هذه الاماكن
دون هذه الاسلحه وبالتالي لا اعتقد انه
بحاجه اليها توصيف هذا المعطى هو تمرد على
السلطه لا احد سواء كان الاتحاد الافريقي
تريد ان ان تقول ان هذا الذي حدث تمرد ومن
ثم
الدعوه الى انهائه الحرب لا تتوقف او
تستمر بسبب الاسلحه او عدمها لكنها تستمر
بسبب الاراده او عجز الاراده عن تح قيق
الصلاه لها مصالح تريد ان
تمت
سياره علماني في السودان